[Music]
Let's start with something that is suddenly
very easy but I want to understand your
answer who or what Bad
Bunny is when you said it was easy I already
knew it
wasn't Bad Bunny I have always said it
like when they ask me who
is Borboni  or that or that is different from
Benito It is nothing other than that I eat
when superheroes have their name
and they look for their suit and they look for their it is the
same it is the same person simply
that well when I am Bad B well maybe
I have
a power or some confidence  beyond
what Benito may have but
at the end of the day he is the same person and
with the same soul the same spirit
let's talk about the Bad or the
businessman Benito Beyond the music who
is that person
this
businessman Benito I would say that  that it has been
created over time and and no While I am
growing As I am finding
other other other ways of being able to
express myself and of and of and
of and of creating
myself at the end of the
day all that part comes from from
music and because  It is what I do that
I am passionate about and thank God because it has
left me fruits that I can continue
to invest in another in another in another in
another area
Ah but Benito is not much different
from a businessman no no it is not
much different  I
say it because one goes
hand in hand with the other.
Oh, because I repeat, it is through
music and everything I have achieved that
gives me the opportunity to create these other
things, eh,
and everything.  What I do, I do it because I
like it and I'm passionate about it. Ah, many times they
come to me. Maybe because of
the focus and they offer me businesses and things
that could possibly
be successful, to
generate a lot of money, something like that, but I
never do it.  I
always do something for money because I like it because
I am passionate about it and because I feel like I can
contribute something and I think that is the
difference between any other
businessman and Benito, the
businessman who is one who for that reason.  I
say that it is very related to
music because what it does is done because it is
passionate about it and because it brings it and because it
wants to contribute something beyond
just Ah well, let me know. Of course
you did feel when you felt that change, if
there was a change,
I think I still need it.  Also that
that super change I think something step by
step while as I say while you
grow when when and when
you are also already established in what
is yours like I have always been very
clear that I have wanted to focus
on  what music is and my career as an
artist and then start
trying other things. Eh, whether it's
business, I know also like in another type
of acting, like when
I have already felt that I am quite
stable and I have achieved  quite within
what is mine, which is music,
well, and you start looking for
other things to do, and as you grow
up, when you are 22 years old and you are
starting out in music, you are only
thinking about what the next one is.
song and now well when
time passes, time passes and you already have more more more
experience you already have more time
also for free time to
do other things and that is where Well, one
begins to let's talk a little about time
you have said that 2023  It's going to be
Benito's year. You feel like it's been like that.
Oh, I don't know if I've fulfilled it 100%. Hey, you
always end up working. Of course,
but oh
yes, I have made time for myself and I
've enjoyed it. And
I
think I've grown a lot and  I have learned
a lot this year
too
and I have
known different places, people,
different things, I have tried new things
too. You can say that 2023
has been a year that I have dedicated myself to myself a
little bit and what is coming for 2024. What is
the next chapter? Let's say  By 2024
I think that there is already working it
again full time this year
we work A parttime Part and in 2024 it is
again from 8 a.  I
'm sleeping, I'm
working, thinking about what I'm going to do
tomorrow. I imagine let's talk a little about
this project that's going to come out in October.
What can you tell us about it? It's a
good project for
my fans. I think they've been
waiting for something like this for a long time.  and and and it is
a project that I did with a lot of
love for them and everything I do I
always do with love and affection
But there are projects where I sometimes think
more about myself than about the fans, there are
projects where I think more about the
fans than about the fans.  me Well here I think I
gave everything to them and I was left
with just a little bit
eh And I think that just because of all the love
and all the support that they have given me
during all this time, it has been
almost 7 years before I was  counting
since 2016 how much it has been and it's almost been
8 years almost more or less eh And seeing
people who are still there following me and
have seen they have been part of my
growth of my evolution and everything
well I think they deserved that that  that
production on my part and and it is something that I
also always wanted
in the len to the boys that I told the
only thing that I wanted to release before I was 30
so after I was 30 I want to
look for another another another another another
inspiration another another another way other
ways of  to express myself with people and
and maybe at that stage so
think a little more about me of course how have you
felt that let's say all these other
projects the performance the crabbers
of Santurce have impacted your
creative process my creative process as I
told you right now I don't  I'm resting I'm sleeping
I'm creating eh And obviously this type
of different Ah activities
different projects
eh They inspire me in some way
sport is something that I have always
liked no no I'm not the best in
sport but I'm very passionate about it  the
sport
Eh
then I would say yes no no I
couldn't tell you in what direct way
But there are many things that I have
learned along the way that also help me
when it comes to creating that of course
it is like in the subconscious Yes this  We
are talking a lot about your fans and
the people who have followed you since
2016 when you are thinking Who is that
fan, not the fan of 2016, the fan of 2023,
the fan of
2030, who is that person, it could be
anyone, I am blessed to  I am
followed by so many people who
think differently about me and of
different ages. I also have people
from children of 5 or 7 years old who
should not listen to all my songs
and I also have adults and people
from 60 to 70 years old.  People who are 80 sometimes stop me
on the street and tell me I am a fan
of yours and my grandson,
so that fan could be
anyone. I have many fans who
have grown up with me, in the
same way that I have evolved and I
myself have learned from them.  They have been
doing it with me, they have also been
learning, they have been evolving
with me.
Oh, and that makes me feel, that makes me
feel proud of what I have done and it
also makes me feel like
we are, I don't want to say a family, but it's
like  This group of friends who
go through experience and as
time passes they change, they are still
the same person and with and with the
same essence But that is what
life is about growing up You can't anymore If you
think the same as you thought 10 ago  years there
is something wrong with you so it is not about
changing your way of being but rather your
way of thinking grows
according to you Eh well part of that
audience is also a global audience
I don't feel like I listen and talk to friends
from Turkey  They say yes, I listen to Bad
Bunny and they don't know how to speak Spanish. How do you
think your music kind of crosses those
borders?
That's the magic of music. First of
all, I believe that we can all
achieve it. Anyone who makes music
can do it.  They say that
music doesn't have a language, it doesn't
have a language, I think it's always been said
that it's because
I let myself be felt in the songs
beyond that. Bass music is
made up of many things beyond what we know.
It may seem simple and and and and there are
people, as I have always said, there are people
with incredible talent in all parts
of the world but
hey, the difficult thing in music is not to be
born with talent because there are many
people with talent. I think that is the
way  in that you connect with
people in that people feel what you
say what you do what you what you
are trying to convey there is
the part where it is a it is a gift of
life that allows you to be
honest  And even more so nowadays, this is
what people look for in music,
honesty, and they feel that they
are really getting to know you. You
are not a character, it is not this artist
who wants to show himself like this in a way and
in  the interviews you want
to express yourself in another way No it's not like
they are seeing that I am me and that
what they see there is what I am
as a person I think that is what
anyone from anywhere can feel
of the world, its
language does not matter, its culture does not matter. It does not matter what
country it is from. They
can perceive it, they can feel it through the
music and what I do. I think
that is what makes me
connect.  With so many people from different
parts of the world, of course how difficult it
was to enter, first let's say leave
Soundcloud and enter Spotify and get to
do the huge tours that you are
doing now. I think that I, I haven't
changed, obviously. Yes, there are many
things that that that that that  I have changed in my
way of working but when it comes to
making
music the formula remains the same
which is to find how to surprise and
how to continue having fun doing it and
focus on that not
on I don't sit in the studio and say
Well, how are we going to conquer Japan now
or how are we going to enter the
Brazilian market or how are we going? I keep making
music thinking about how
my friends like it
and that people in Puerto Rico like it
when I go out.  the street and I listened to the
cars, my music, that's what I
always keep focused on when I'm going
to make music, I haven't changed that
formula and from there, the world
adopts it and and and
and it's still like that, no, I haven't changed
in  that aspect who are your
inspirations Let's start on the
music side and then we go to the business side hand
That question is one that is always asked
and they ask me and I I have never dared
to say a name in particular because
because I am well F the  music since
I was little and, as I always say, at home we
heard a lot of salsa coming from my country, it
was a lot of ballads, a lot of merengue from the
Dominican Republic of Puerto Rico,
so here I was as a child
from the 90s.  I was born in the 90s but
I grew up older in the
2000s because obviously I wanted to listen to
reggaeton I wanted to listen to more rap I wanted to
listen to more then well And as
you grow up go to university and
start exploring another genre there are many
people many artists of different
genres  from different countries from
different
eras that I feel are inside
me eh
eh if we let ourselves be carried away by the
reggaeton genre Well, I have always said that
what Teo Calderón was was I think that she was one of
those first artists that I became
obsessed with and wanted  and I wanted to do what
this bicos did, who was the first
rap and urban artist that I heard
for the first time and then here comes
Dari yanke Don Omar wiel
este Calle 13
René
Ed and buo and many more exponents of the
reggaetón genre than me
I always listened and and and I always say that they are
part of that inspirations But in addition
to that I can also be in another genre
all day Here mention your
name and artist and and genres that
have been part of my training
let's talk a little about the
inspiration from the business side some
artist who has grown And you say wow I
want I want to do that I want to have
expand let's say my influence Beyond
the music as I told you right now I
am not a person of of of of of
that I follow such a negotiating Not all
All the business opportunities that have been
given to me have been thanks to the success I
have had in music and it has been a
process of growth in
wanting to expand in that
area so I am the same as I do with
music I believe  I am inspired by
all those people who really
do it and when I say that they do it, it
is because they take the step, many people
say I am going to do this, I am going to do
that and they have many plans and and they are
good ideas but no no  They try it,
no, no, not against it. So I think that I am
inspired by those people from the
neighborhood of the town who, with little,
but with The Initiative and with the
necessary work, they do a lot. I
come from a neighborhood.  I have seen it, I have
seen how this person who started with
little And is growing And is growing and
I is doing I believe that those are the
people who really
inspire me to grow too I know that
you are also part of this competition
What are we doing in October are you going to
donate 00,000 to the no small business this
Latino What is the importance of doing
that I think that because of what I just
said
sometimes those same people who sometimes do
n't don't take the first step is because
Maybe they don't have the resources or they don't have
the
support I
simply want to be that that
that motivation ex and it's that push
that can change maybe
someone's day or even their life eh And that's what it is that
At least I
always like to do, I like to see
another person succeed and see another
person achieve what they dream of and knowing
that I can be part of that
process is super cool and not in a
way like after  I'm going to
hold it against you No thanks to me, no, on the
contrary, it's like I feel like
I was part of it with you and
and and that's all. I think it
always fills me up that in some way that's what
you're doing with Good Bunny.
foundation we can't talk a little
about that how you created that let's say
that idea came to you to create a foundation
Oh I think it comes from that
feeling of always wanting to contribute
something and
help I come back and repeat I I I come
from a neighborhood I  I know what
needs are, upbringing, I also look
at my house, I saw how my dad
is always contributing to the neighborhood
without having much. Do you understand me about how little
we had and sometimes when I was a child, I did
n't even understand it, sometimes there was a  pair
of shoes that were I had two
shoes the only ones I had and my dad
gave him look that here the boy
needs it and I but daddy those are mine and I did
n't understand those things and now as an adult I
see it in a different way and  that generosity
and that way of wanting to help,
it's not just when you
have it, it comes from the heart,
so I think that in this position, it
's not just a pair of shoes,
but of course,
it's much more.  What I can contribute
to the community and especially to the
children
Ah,
there are many things that I would have
loved to have as a child eh a
lot of resources initiative program eh
As I told you right now I have always liked
sports I have always liked music
and I  I have witnessed how sports
and music can change anyone's
life, little kids from the
neighborhood who made it and are now in
the Major Leagues doing I don't know about
boxing in music and how their lives
change course from  of maybe being
on the street or in some things that
don't don't leave anything good to see them how they
have how they have managed to succeed in
life Well that's the the the the the
main intention to be able to encourage and
give the tool to the  children of of of of of of
give to him That that alternative that in
the music and in the sport they can can
succeed in life so that they are the
next pat bu if you could speak with the
Benito of 2015 let's say not the 2016 2015
what would
you say to him hand what would you say to him  no, no, I wouldn't
tell him a lot because he did it, you
bastard,
no, whatever follows him
around, I would say, he's still around, maybe I'd
tell him that he shouldn't be
careless about eating crap and start
exercising since
2015. Well, okay, and if you could tell him
Benito, let's say about 2040, what do you want me to
remember about this moment in your
life? Something that I don't want to forget. There are
many things that I wouldn't want to
forget. This year has been a very
nice year, last year also my
stadium tour in the  United States and
complete America was a
very nice experience
eh Argentina Mexico Costa Rica
Peru well and all the countries that I went
was an experience that at that
moment is being lived it is like
that
things and it is recent but Exactly when
I am 40 or not you saw  of 2040 this Wow
I wish
Ah I would like to remind myself of that
of all the experiences that
I have been living in the last few years
of that of that tour that was very special
and And of all these moments that maybe
no no no maybe no no  They are going to come back What
was the moment the best moment of
your career so far the best moment
of my
career hand I never have that answer
because every day is the best
moment of my real career every
year is the best moment of my  career
everything, every step I take is the best, it
's a bigger step and that's how it's been.
That's how it's been from the beginning and I
remember when I released
chambea I'm worse and I said devil and what a
bigger song I'm going to release now
and later  So that's like that doesn't
exist for me there is no limit there
is no ceiling and and and we continue working and
doing things that take us to another
level and to another level and when
the levels no longer exist we create it
So the best moment of my
career  I'll be able to tell you when it's over
right now maybe a good answer hasn't come
and the most difficult moment the most
difficult moment I think it's the beginning
when you're adapting when when
in my case that my life changed
drastically from one day to the next
eh  Assimilating that and being able to see the light
again was like the most difficult thing, as
at the moment being used to always
being with your family and at the moment being
traveling the world every day, you don't
like airplanes, I don't like
airplanes and  moment you are living in
one like that uh that
change that change I think that uh it
was the most difficult moment of my of
my career to be able to adapt and assimilate
everything like that At the moment everything was very
fast and I was not even present I
felt like in  one like an
autopilot like a and assimilate all that and
and accept it and and it was I think the
most difficult part of my career and to
finish what do you want your legacy to be
Ah my legacy hand I I have always said
I
[Music]
I do it  I am who I am, I am a
person, everything I do I do it for the reason
why I feel it and because I
like it because I am passionate about it I
am not working so that people will talk about me or so that
or so that 30 years from now
say this is part of how you
can't escape
but let that be my legacy a person
who always did things from the
heart and that and that worked for him that that
was what that was the the the the
perfect formula for for  reach out or
act from the heart and always do
things because you feel them, not because
someone hears you or you think it's what you have
to do to
get there, thank you Benito for everything again,
thank you for having us Yes,
[Music]
we are here